السماء فوق أوكرانيا، كان هناك هذا،
هذه هي أوكرانيا تسقط
طائرات بدون طيار وصواريخ روسية فوق أوديسا
لليلة الثانية على التوالي،
أصيب العديد من الأشخاص وتضررت محطات الحبوب هذه، كما
تتذكرون قبل
يومين فقط، انسحبت روسيا من الصفقة
السماح لأوكرانيا بتصدير الحبوب من
موانئ أوديسا قال الرئيس التركي
إنه سيتحدث إلى الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين حول إمكانية
إحياء تلك الصفقة الذهنية، تم التوصل إلى
الاتفاق الأخير بوساطة مايك تركيا والأمم
المتحدة في عام 2022، والآن قالت روسيا إنها
ستكون مستعدة للعودة إلى الصفقة
إذا  يتم تلبية مطالب موسكو الآن.
يقوم أردوغان بجولة في منطقة الخليج
لتعزيز الاستثمار الأجنبي للاقتصاد التركي
المتعثر. موجود حاليًا في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة منذ فترة قصيرة. لقد
تحدثت مع
كبير مستشاري أردوغان للسياسة الخارجية والأمن، لكن
نوايا تركيا  من المحتمل التوسط في
صفقة أخرى بين روسيا وأوكرانيا بمجرد
عودة السيد أردوغان إلى الوطن استمع
لذلك جدول الرئيس
مزدحم للغاية الآن لذلك نحن أه نحن في
الطريق وأه بالطبع كما
ذكرت مبادرة البحر الأسود أو
الصفقة الخضراء أه  كما يشير الجميع إليها، لقد
وصلت إلى الحد الزمني المحدد ولكن
فرقنا تعمل عليها والرئيس
أردوغان أيضًا
منخرط جدًا في هذه القضية لمحاولة
التوصل إلى اتفاق ولكن بالطبع هناك
الكثير من الأمور كما تعلمون
الأطراف المختلفة هنا  منخرطون ونحن كتركيا
سنقوم بدورنا وحاضر أردوغان
يريد أن نعود أه من زيارتنا
سوف نتحقق مما يمكننا القيام به
أعلن الرئيس أردوغان مؤخرًا أن
الرئيس بوتين من المقرر أن يزور تركيا
في أغسطس، ولم يؤكد الكرملين
ذلك حتى الآن
لا يزال يحدث وإذا كان الأمر كذلك فهل
لدينا جدول زمني نخطط فيه
لزيارة الرئيس بوتين في أغسطس ولكن
بالطبع لا أستطيع التعليق هنا على
المواقع الروسية أه أو على
إعلاناتهم ولكننا نخطط
ونعمل أه الرئيس بوتين في تركيا
انظر لقد كان بوتين دائمًا
يتعامل بشكل كبير في المفاوضات إذا
رأينا اتفاق اللحظة الأخيرة لأن هذا هو
الأمل الآن ماذا تتوقع
أن تكون مطالبه هي ما
نعرفه من أه من اتصالاتنا
ومحادثاتنا مع جميع شركائنا
وأيضًا أه ما هو  أه مع الجانب الروسي
وأن هناك بعض الأمور
غير راضين عنها أه وأنهم
يشيرون إلى
أم الوعود التي أعطيت
للصفقة الكبرى واتفاق تم
التوصل إليه ولم يتم الوفاء به لذلك علينا
العمل عليه  من الواضح أن هذا مقطع
فيديو يركز فعليًا على
المناطق الأكثر حظًا في العالم،
أود أن أضع الأمر بهذه الطريقة في
البلدان المستقلة عن
الحبوب والتي تأتي من هذه
الصفقة لذلك نحن  سوف تعمل على ذلك